[Applause]
cheered on by the medical staff who
cared for her Nicoletta tuna finally
left the hospital she spent a year in
after getting severe covered at eight
months pregnant doctors had to deliver
her baby early and put her into a coma
she would only wake up from four months
later
one of the nurses who is from my country
looked at me and said you are a miracle
okay but why and after that I asked her
what date is today and she said he's 22
22 of February 2022. I know I can't
believe even then prognosis for
Nicoletta originally from Romania was
Bleak
what is your last wish yeah oh my God I
start to cry because I can't believe you
can ask me
and I said I want to lie with my with my
kids and I'm and I want to see how they
grow
so this is my last wish and she may have
that wish granted despite spending a
record time on an ECMO machine
essentially an artificial lung staff who
treated her say she's beaten the odds
she is an absolute miracle and after the
longevity of her
um being on ECMO to be able to get home
to her family after 299 days on ECMO is
absolutely outstanding it's not
something that we've done before you can
consider it very very work as we haven't
heard it I think so in UK we haven't
heard it a beach and stained that long
on ECMO so she's been really rude to us
and that was a complex case to deal with
but yeah she made it so we are happy she
made it it would be 11 months before
Nicoletta could hold her baby girl for
the first time now firmly In Her Arms
she and her husband who drove three
hours each day to see her are moving
forward I believe this is the the
feeling like when you're willing to
ability
is like
everything that you wish in your life is
is there you can just grab it and that's
it it's yours nobody will gonna take it
from you oh under the same roof reunited
at last
Sky News
[Music]